you like the imac pro don't you marquez
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and in my
last video in that wwdc recap we talked
a little bit about the brand new
announced imac pro and i kind of
mentioned it possibly being a little bit
of a trap and i wanted to elaborate on
that a little bit so keep in mind this
is a brand new product and it was
announced but we're not actually going
to see it until about six months down
the road it's going to be in december of
this year pretty rare move from apple
but this is until then everything we
know is definitely true about the new
imac pro so first off it's gonna look
from the outside
like any other imac but space gray so
this behind me is the brand new 2017
kaby lake 27 inch imac and it's a pretty
high end machine in a lot of ways by
itself the imac pro takes this shell
this exact same body paints it matte
black or space gray if you want to call
it that and completely redoes all the
inside so for the imac pro cpu you'll be
able to pick between an 8 core
10 core or 18 core workstation grade
intel xeon cpu this will have turbo
speeds up to 4.5 gigahertz out the box
absolute monster chips it'll also have a
choice between amd radeon vega
workstation gpus which aren't even
announced yet this event was basically
an announcement for these graphics cards
because you can't find them anywhere
else it'll start at 32 gigs of ecc
memory and will go up to
128 gigs of ram and it's all flash
storage ssd only so it'll start at one
terabyte of flash storage and go up to
four terabytes of flash storage and it's
fast flash storage at about three
gigabytes per second throughput so
awesome there and what's really
interesting is the imac pro will have
this new completely redesigned thermal
architecture to make this all possible
sounds a lot like the trashcan mac pro
lots of workstation parts crammed into a
small space with a completely new
thermal architecture and new fans to
make it all possible and then of course
up front it'll also have this updated 5k
display it's updated meaning it's a
little bit brighter up to 500 nits it
supports the entire p3 color gamut it's
already a great display it's a little
glossy for my tastes and we'll get to
that in a little bit but it's already a
pretty great 5k panel and then the ports
on the back of the imac are updated as
well so you get your headphone jack you
get an sd card slot 4 usb 3 ports 4
thunderbolt 3 usb c ports and a 10 gig
ethernet port and back there you can
also see the new vents on the back that
aren't on the backs of normal imacs so
some serious ventilation to go along
with this new cooling system and then as
a nice little touch the imac pro comes
with some exclusive space grey
accessories a matte gray track pad a
matte gray magic keyboard with number
pad and a gray magic mouse to top it all
off so
should you buy it who is going to buy an
imac pro well first off this imac this
highest end regular 2017 imac is already
a pretty high-end machine in a lot of
ways like we said and it's probably more
power than most enthusiasts or casual
users just buying an imac ever really
need the imac pro
leap frogs all of this and it actually
even leapfrogs the current trashcan mac
pro in terms of power but then you have
to expect the new modular mac pro coming
next year to even leapfrog that and it's
going to be modular so it's going to be
way more upgradable down the line better
expandability upgradeability
customization etc and the imac pro isn't
coming out till december like we said so
by the time that comes out and you're
getting your hands on it the new modular
mac pro will be right around the corner
and then second off apple's made it
pretty clear that the vast majority of
people that are buying apple desktops
apple mac desktops are buying imacs and
that makes perfect sense i mean what
other choices do you have you have the
mac mini pretty small not that powerful
not very popular you might have
forgotten it existed and then you have
mac pro a little more niche a little
more expensive not a lot of people
buying it so of course if you're buying
a mac for your desktop you're buying an
imac so with that logic apple said all
right you know what we want to make an
even more powerful desktop for all these
people who are pushing imac to its
limits you want an even more powerful
workstation machine that's where the
idea of imac pro was born but the thing
is those aren't the actual professionals
most of the time and the people who
chose the mac pro over the imac
chose it for a certain reason and those
same people are most likely going to
choose the new mac pro over the imac pro
again so basically the question is what
buyer is there is there a buyer that's
going to want a more high-end machine a
workstation grade mac that's more
powerful than the current imac but can't
wait for the new mac pro to come out a
pretty impatient one basically and
that's kind of why it seems like a trap
basically imac pro is in this really
specific narrow target demographic in
this awkward space above the current
imac but where people are not getting
the future mac pro they're kind of still
okay with the all in one design i'm sure
this thing will be great for all sorts
of content creators for youtubers or for
like photographers and people who like
the current imac and we're getting away
with using that for all their editing
that's still a great machine it's still
a great display all of that still
remains but you have to know if you're
in that target demographic or if you're
just too impatient to wait for the new
mac prep this thing will be an absolute
beast i have no doubts about that that's
supported by everything we see on paper
the specs are awesome but the biggest
downside for me with this thing is of
course that it's not really upgradable
just like the current imacs it doesn't
appear to have a ram hatch like previous
imacs have so that's not upgradable and
ifixit says that you can technically get
to the cpu and change it if you want but
most people won't be doing that so
you're expected to live with the specs
that you buy for the entire life of the
machine and that's what separates it
from the new modular mac pro that we're
still expecting the 5k display is great
you know but what if i want to upgrade
to a not glossy display or maybe an 8k
display a year or two down the road you
know the gpus are great but what if in a
year or two gpus have gotten way better
and i want to upgrade it to a newer
better compatible one it's just that
all-in-ones like the imac have to be
replaced
all in one and it's kind of hard to get
rid of an imac pro that starts at 5000
bucks when a couple new gpus come out
and that's just the starting price at
49.99 but it's anyone's guess what the
highest end fully loaded imac pro will
cost my guess will be to be around 9 000
that's my guess maybe you can leave your
guesses in the comments section below
but that's pretty much it that's the
imac pro explained in a nutshell we have
six months to see what it actually looks
like until then thank you for watching
talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]
you